let's talk about virtue signaling
the right says that they are against
so-called virtue signaling now virtue
signaling is
when you publicly express an opinion to
try to signal
that you are morally on the right side
of something or to signal that your
character is to be respected
um and republican arizona governor doug
ducey
is doing exactly this he has issued an
executive order
banning so-called vaccine passports of
which there are none
in arizona nor were any coming as
described by his executive order
first question what is a vaccine
passport well the executive order would
ban
state and local governments in arizona
from requiring
arizonans uh to provide
proof of covet vaccination either to go
into some kind of government building or
to receive
something he tweeted about it saying
quote i've issued an executive order
banning vaccine passports and preventing
state and local governments
from requiring arizonans to provide
their covet 19 vaccination status
to receive service or enter an area
do you see going on to tweet that quote
the residents of our state should not be
required by the government to share
their private medical information
more on that later while we strongly
recommend all arizonans get the vaccine
it's not mandated in our state and it
never will be
now the logical question would be was
the state of arizona about to mandate
people need to get vaccinated
was the state of arizona or were
municipalities
about to say you need a vaccine in order
to go to this government building or
that or
no no nobody this was never going to
happen
so first of all this executive order is
focused on something which wasn't
actually going to be taking place
now uh uh second question is
does this actually apply to those who
might
require a vaccination like a school
or a business it does not it would not
prevent that
if the phoenix sun's nba team says you
know what
at some point once you know maybe by
next next season
to come to our games you're going to
need to provide proof of vaccination
this executive order does nothing to
stop that the phoenix suns could legally
do that if they want to do it
schools can require vaccinations schools
have required vaccinations for decades
in arizona just for different vaccines
and so not only is this virtue signaling
trash
executive order meant to stop something
which was not going to happen which is
mandatory vaccination per arizona
or governments municipalities requiring
the vaccine or requiring it to do
something that was never going to happen
this is going to create anti-vaxxers
who will have heard of this and then
they will go
to a business or their kid will need a
vaccine to go to school and they will
show up and film themselves saying
ducey pass the law against this and of
course he didn't
the executive order is about what
government
will or won't do with regard to
vaccination it has nothing to do with
businesses it has nothing to do with
schools
so uh it's it's it's a
combination of pointless virtue
signaling
with the addition of creating more
problems for schools and businesses
who are able to require a coronavirus
vaccination now a related topic
in that second tweet ducey said
residents of our state
should not be required by the government
to share their private medical
information
now is he on the same page with that
claim when it comes to
which bathroom a trans person wants to
use
or does he want it to be forced that
they need to provide proof of their
biological sex at birth is he on the
same page when it comes to
women and abortion or does the phrase
residents of our state should not be
required by the government to share
private medical information
only apply to covet vaccination
requirements this guy is pathetic
one of the worst of the worst one of the
worst handlings
in the country of the coronavirus
pandemic and now
the executive order which doesn't
actually deal with what people think it
deals with
and deals only with something that was
never going to happen
we're going to have more coverage of a
so-called
uh vaccine mandate conspiracism
on our instagram page at david pakman
show
and if you want to see one of our dutch
viewers yesterday in a supermarket
saw an advertisement for beer and it
looked like
i was on the advertisement it's actually
really strange i posted it to my
instagram you can find me
at david.pakman